LOUIS GRAY: And welcome back.
Thanks for doing those
Sandbox interviews.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah.
My pleasure.
LOUIS GRAY: It was a lot of fun
to see exactly what the
developers are seeing,
especially with Google+, since
it is a fairly new platform
in terms of Google.
I wanted to ask you real quick,
what did the developers
say to you that really
struck you?
What was it about their initial
interaction with
Google+ and Google+ sign in that
they're finding, and how
are their users responding?
DANIEL SIEBERG: You know,
universally, first of all,
they said that their experience
with the Google+
team on the development side was
fantastic, that they were
there with them every step of
the way, understanding new
ways that they can kind
of iterate on Google+.
And as you say, it is a
relatively new way for
developers to think about
including it in any site,
whether it's the sign in, or
Hangouts, or whatever it is.
And they were really kind of
pushing what was possible, and
thinking of new ways to do it,
which I thought was really
cool, and they were extremely
complimentary
of the Google+ team.
LOUIS GRAY: And one thing I
think that's really been
highlighted, not only in our
discussion of Google I/O, what
we're focused on at this entire
conference-- but even
the press response has been
absolutely solid this year--
is seeing how closely
we're focused
on a developer community.
You know, obviously we have a
lot of really interesting
services that impact consumers,
but this is all
about developers at
this conference.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah.
Almost every story that I've
read about this has referenced
that in some way, that it is a
huge acknowledgement to that
developer community.
That yes, of course there are
things here that consumers are
interested in, however, the bulk
of the announcements and
the conversations here are
really targeted at developers.
LOUIS GRAY: As someone who works
in developer relations
and runs Google Developers
Live, that's
like music to my ears.
And so I'm really excited to
see that the developers are
hearing what we've been saying,
and making their
applications better for users
with the APIs and the tools
that we've given them.
And one thing I wanted to look
at, when you look at
yesterday's keynote, we had a
really interesting updated to
Google Play.
And not only did Google Play
get a refresh-- and like we
said, it looks the same
across mobile,
and tablet, and desktop.
DANIEL SIEBERG: From a
design standpoint.
LOUIS GRAY: From a design
standpoint.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah, the UI.
LOUIS GRAY: But one of the
things that was especially
important was really what Google
takes to the heart of
everything we do, is data, and
making sure that they have the
analytics of that data.
And so you look about a Google+
sign in user, and you
look at really any Android
application development user,
you basically have a situation
where you can count exactly
how many installs you
have, whether
that's going up or down.
And, to improve the type of
analytics, to help you do a
better job of marketing your
devices, marketing your
applications, and seeing what's
working and what's not.
I thought it was especially
important to take the
learnings that we have from
Google Analytics, where we can
really tell you what's happening
on your website in
real time, and tell you ways to
improve your campaigns from
a marketing perspective.
But to do that on Google
Play just make sense.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah, and to be
able to do that rapidly and
strategically, and get that
feedback through Google
Analytics, I think that was
something that a lot of these
developers were craving for
a long time, frankly.
And now that they have that
ability, as you say, to kind
of make those changes
very quickly, I
think that's very powerful.
I mean, this is, ultimately at
the end of the day, we're
talking about building your
revenue, and making sure that
you're targeting those people,
and that you're hitting all
the right places to
get those results.
LOUIS GRAY: And especially
for those people for whom
development is not a hobby.
It's their lifeblood.
You know, they make profit or
they don't make a profit
depending on how well they
market their applications, how
well they build their
applications, and how well
they get them in the hands of
consumers who can give you
immediate feed back in Google
Play as to whether that's
working or not.
And so I think the real sweet
attention to detail, and being
able to help people promote it
and get that right, I think we
have incredible tools including
Translation.
How do you go ahead and
translate your application.
There's a way even with
integration with Google
Wallet-- it was really quick
they did that demo-- but you
can go in and say, I need this
application translated into
Russian, or French, or whatever
those ones that you
need to knock out.
And with a quick payment through
Google Wallet, you can
go ahead and get that translated
and shipped off
through the Google Play store,
and that really seemed like
good attention to detail.
You take and harness, as we said
yesterday, you harness
the data center of Google,
you harness the
internationalization, and the
real depth and scale that only
Google can offer through Google
Play, and bring it to
developers so they can really
make more money, and have
happier users.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah, and
including in the game space
too, with the game services.
You know, when we talked to Greg
and Duncan from the game
side yesterday, what they're
working on, and I believe it's
30 launch partners that they
have got right now, and the
kinds of innovative games that
they're working on with that
community is amazing to me.
I mean, the--
LOUIS GRAY: You know,
30 doesn't sound
like a lot to us today.
When you look at the growth of
Google, every time I look at
this I/O, you see the
numbers go up.
You look at the 100 million, to
400 million, to 900 million
Android, you've got to think
when you start to set the
foundation, and you
do that right--
you know, today we've got a
Sandbox of Google+ partners,
and we've got a Sandbox full
of games partners, what is
that really going to look
like next year?
When you set the foundation and
you build out the correct
tools so developers can do a
better job for users, and it's
really and incredible thing.
Next year, how many different
people we're going to be
talking to, and what
those numbers are
going to look like.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah, and I want
to just reference numbers
little bit, because you and I
yesterday talked to the cloud
folks, and the numbers that
they're talking about in terms
of the latency and the--
LOUIS GRAY: Milliseconds.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah,
milliseconds, and then the
storage capabilities that's
possible today, those numbers
are heading in some amazing
directions.
LOUIS GRAY: Right.
You've got milliseconds down
at the latency side, and
you've got trillions and
trillions of numbers--
DANIEL SIEBERG: That are
being processed.
Yeah, I mean, this is kind of
mind blowing kind of stuff.
LOUIS GRAY: Right, and that's
the type of thing, when you
look at Google scale, this isn't
something that's very
simple to replicate, and you
have to really spend.
I think Greg talked about
it yesterday.
They spent $2.6 billion dollars
on infrastructure, and
that's a little bit of money,
and is the right thing to do,
because it makes everybody's
experience better.
We talked about moving the
bottleneck around.
That's something that
I have experience.
You know, I have a long history
in IT, and working on
network storage, and things
like that, and so you know
you've got to move that
bottleneck around, be it the
infrastructure and the
computation to the network.
And this Google continues to
follow that, and make sure the
bottlenecks get out of the way,
so you can focus not only
on your applications, but the
user experience is really
incredible.
And I wanted to transition
to something else.
We had an opportunity yesterday
to talk with Nicolas
Garnier for Drive.
Google Drive is one year old
at Google I/O this year.
They had incredible growth,
incredible API development to
work with developers so
they can do real time
collaboration, a lot of really
interesting things.
And even use Drive as a hosted
website platform, and you had
an opportunity go talk to the
Drive Sandbox yesterday.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah,
that's right.
They're in the Google partner
apps area, and there are a
couple of companies, and we
talked to FedEx about what
they're doing, and we
talked to a group of
HelloSign and HelloFax.
In both cases, I felt like
I really need to
have both of these.
I did not know about
them ahead of time.
And I think that the way that
Drive is integrating with
these types of--
in one case, they're a somewhat
traditional company
with FedEx, and a relatively
new company.
And the way that they're
thinking about how Drive can
integrate with their services
is fascinating.
LOUIS GRAY: One thing, and
you mentioned HelloFax.
Here we are in 2013, and we're
bringing new ways to
communicate still.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Fax is
not dead at all.
LOUIS GRAY: No, faxing is a very
traditional business, and
a tradition way of
communicating.
How do you take that into a
connected web way, and so I'm
looking forward to that.
If we could go ahead and take
a look at the Sandbox video
from yesterday with Daniel
talking to Drive.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Hi there.
I'm Daniel Sieberg with
Google Developers
Live here at I/O 2013.
We're at the Google Apps
partners showcase, and I am
talking right now with Joel from
HelloFax and HelloSign,
and we'll get into
both of those.
So tell me a little bit about
what HelloFax is, first of
all, and how it ties into Drive,
because that's really
what we're going to talk
about in a second.
JOEL ANDREN: Sure.
So HelloFax turns Drive
into a fax machine.
It allows you to send and
receive faxes as easy as it is
to send and receive an email.
So you don't have to worry
about the whole printers,
scanner, toner, all
that stuff.
JOEL ANDREN: Is that fax sound,
that dialing sound, is
that optional?
JOEL ANDREN: We might do that as
a plug-in later, but right
now we don't have that.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Right,
OK cool.
So walk me through how this
works within Drive.
JOEL ANDREN: Sure, and actually
what I'll do is show
you HelloSign, because it's
the same process.
All you do is you upload a
document, and then you can
mark it up.
So if you take a
document here--
let me see here--
upload a document, and what you
do is you edit and sign a
document, and then you add in a
fax number, or you add in an
email address.
So what you do here is you see
the markups of the document--
let me find one here--
and it allows you to add a
signature, it allows you to
add a check box.
And what I'll do is I'll show
you how to do a signature,
because what happens a lot,
people and they need to sign a
document, they need to get a
contract signed, an invoice.
You basically bring in your
signature and you drop it in,
and you insert it there.
You can draw that with a mouse,
but I actually am going
to go with one that I've already
uploaded it in terms
of an image file, so I'll
use my saved one.
And you insert that into a
document, and then you can
move that around.
DANIEL SIEBERG: So
this is great.
I mean, previously you would
either have to print it out,
or scan it, or something like
that, all of those things.
JOEL ANDREN: So everything is
online, and everything is
within Drive.
So you can turn around a
contract or send out a fax in
about 30 seconds, rather than
driving to Kinko's, walking
over to the printer, and
everything like that, so it's
all self-contained, and it's
all Google integrated.
We also have a great integration
with Gmail, so you
can actually see here, view,
download, or sign.
So you can sign a document in
Gmail, never need to leave
Gmail, never need to leave the
services you like to go ahead
and sign a document.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And then you
can see all those documents
within your Drive.
JOEL ANDREN: They show up
automatically in your Drive,
your Sent and Receive folder,
so all your important
documents are where you care
about them the most.
DANIEL SIEBERG: So tell me
about the experience of
working with Drive team, and
HelloFax, and HelloSign,
working with those folks.
How's that been?
JOEL ANDREN: Yeah, the Drive
team has been awesome, and
what we've really found is the
they're really responsive to
what we've been looking for
and looking to do, and we
actually have a new service
coming out which allows you to
upload documents directly from
your mail, and send them off
to Drive, and it's really
sort of seamless.
So they've really responsive,
and we use Google Drive as a
proxy for our service, and in
many cases you don't even need
to come to our site to do it.
DANIEL SIEBERG: This
is fantastic.
I have to sign up
for HelloSign--
JOEL ANDREN: Please do.
DANIEL SIEBERG: --and HelloFax.
All right.
Joel, thank you so much.
JOEL ANDREN: Thanks a lot.
DANIEL SIEBERG: I
apprecite it.
The next partner that we're
going to deliver to you is one
that's no stranger to
deliveries, and that is FedEx.
But in this case, we're talking
about FedEx Office,
and how that ties into Drive,
and documents, and the ability
to make these really cool
presentations, and then have
them delivered to you.
So I'm joined right now by Lee
from FedEx, so Lee, talk to me
about how it integrates with
Drive, how FedEx Drive.
LEE HUNT: Yeah, we've just
recently introduced a new
Google Drive app that basically
allows you to port
any and drop a wider range of
file types directly from
Google Drive directly into our
print online interface.
Which is a really high end,
designing type application
that allows you to create
finishing options for your
documents, including binding,
coils, covers, tabs, anything
that you want to associate with
creating physical print,
we're able to do and transport
your Google Drive file into
that type of document.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And then it
gets delivered to you.
That final product gets
delivered to you.
LEE HUNT: You can actually
choose to have it delivered to
you, or you can actually have
it chosen to be picked up in
any of our 1800 locations
nationwide.
DANIEL SIEBERG: So walk
me through what
it looks like here.
LEE HUNT: So we have a variety
of supported file types with
our app, so it's just a matter
of being within the Drive
interface after you install the
app, and selecting those
files and just right
clicking, selecting
Open with FedEx Office.
And essentially what that does
is it launches up our print
online application, and it
grabs those documents and
ports it into that
particular tool.
I'm going to jump ahead a little
bit and show you kind
of what it looks like.
So this is a file that we pulled
in earlier, and it was
a plain, basically Google
document, that we're able to
show right now as we're
building it.
You can almost see a soft proof
of what it'd look like
to be produced and finished
at FedEx Office.
You can see with the coil
binding, and we can change
that to add binders, spines, a
number of various options that
people find useful when they're
producing such documents.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And then folks
can pay for all of this right
here, and select the option
that want to get it?
LEE HUNT: Yeah.
They can choose their closest
FedEx Office location through
the interface, and like you
said, yeah, choose to ship it
to their house if they
don't even want
to leave their couch.
They can sit in their
pajamas and do all
this right from there.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Now, there's
even a tie in with mobile too,
as people want to access to
these documents, and have a
similar experience on
a mobile device.
JOEL ANDREN: Exactly.
So recently we actually
introduced our new FedEx
Office mobile app, and our
mobile app also ties into
Google Drive.
Basically allowing you to
directly grab a file from
Google Drive within our mobile
app, and pretty much do
exactly the same that's within
our full-fledged e-commerce
application.
Really offering customers a
subset of those particular
options, like if they want to
create a flier, or a poster, a
presentation, give them
some basic options.
And once again, through the
app, they can pay for the
finished product, and
have it shipped or
picked up from any location.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And just
quickly, how was the
experience working with Drive
team from FedEx's standpoint?
LEE HUNT: Fantastic,
really supportive.
They were really there to
answer any questions
that we need to.
Just a really great experience
overall.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Great.
Lee, thank you so much.
We appreciate it.
And that's going to do for the
Google Apps partner showcase.
I'm Daniel Sieberg with Google
Developers Live.
Stay tuned for lots
more content.